est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec le
fait que cette commission d'enquête vise
uniquement les violences des casseurs et
non pas les violences de certains
policiers qui existent aussi pour vous
le chant de la Commission et bon faut
pas se voiler la face quand même vu ce
qu'on a vu pendant les manifestations
contre les retraites pendant
Sainte-Souline effectivement il y a
quand même un vrai sujet qui est
l'influence et l'implication de l'ultra
gauche des casseurs dans la violence
dans les manifestations et le fait que
notre majorité donc Aurore berger notre
présidente de groupe et Laurent Marco
njelli le président du groupe horizon
souhaite cette commission d'enquête
c'est une chose absolument nécessaire et
que les Français veulent on ne veut plus
t'es casseurs dans nos mafé
manifestation il faut trouver des
solutions après moi j'ai des échangé
avec Florent Boudier puisque c'est passé
en commission hier et que c'est lui qui
va être rapporteur dans cette commission
d'enquête lui a tenu effectivement à
entendre nos oppositions et à ce que à
l'occasion de cette commission d'enquête
on puisse aussi avoir la lumière sur
l'ensemble des violences on a eu un
débat à l'Assemblée nationale mardi
d'ailleurs dans le cadre de la Semaine
de contrôle et moi je suis aussi
intervenu sur ce sujet y compris on
souhaite que la lumière et la
transparence soit faite sur l'ensemble
des violences bien sûr les proportions
ne sont pas les mêmes on a une
soixantaine d'enquêtes aujourd'hui
administratives et pénale contre des
policiers qui auraient commis des
débordements et bien il faut que ces
enquêtes soient suivies que le Parlement
est connaissance de l'ensemble de
l'efficacité de tout ce qui est fait
dans ce cadre là mais notre cible
principale ça reste comment ces
groupuscules sont structurés financés
pour infiltrer nos manifestations
aujourd'hui à l'extérieur comme au 1er
mai devant le cortège à l'arrière du
cortège mais demain nous ne voulons pas
que ce soit à l'intérieur alors germes
de Darmanin le mistraux intérieur
travail sur une nouvelle loi
anti-casseurs violette spielboot est-ce
que ce serait une bonne idée de remettre
sur la table cette mesure d'interdiction
administrative de manifester pour
certaines personnes
c'est assez compliqué juridiquement et
constitutionnellement il y a déjà une
loi anti-casseurs qui existent je crois
que le ministre de la Justice le
ministre de l'Intérieur se voit ce
vendredi et vont travailler dans les
jours à venir pour voir si il faut mieux
renforcer l'application de la loi
anti-casseur aujourd'hui ou avoir des
mesures législatives supplémentaires la
question du contrôle a priori avant les
manifestations normalement sur la
confiscation des armes par exemple ou
l'identité de certaines personnes qui
seraient fichée peut se poser parce que
finalement les Français qui nous
interpellent ils nous disent pourquoi
vous les empêchez pas de venir dans les
manifestations c'est facile dans un lieu
fermé dans un stade où on peut avoir des
contrôles c'est facile aussi parce que
la loi le permet dans les manifestations
interdites de faire des contrôles à
priori comme c'était le cas à Sainte
Soline et des confiscations d'armes en
revanche sur une manifestation autorisée
aujourd'hui la Constitution ne le permet
pas donc
leur méthode
change il cache les armes avant ils
viennent trois quatre jours avant tout
tous ces casseurs ont des ressorts très
nouveau le digital etc il faut que nous
on s'adapte on a déjà expérimenté les
drones le 1er mai dans beaucoup de lieux
de manifestations en France ça a évité
un incendie grave à la mairie de Lyon
c'est donc efficace sur beaucoup de
situations il va falloir qu'on continue
de s'adapter et c'est là-dessus que les
deux ministres travaillent aujourd'hui
[Musique]